ん
あった
ブーフーウーだ
ています
みなさんこんにちは
生き辛かというものをテーマにしたウェブマガジンを運営しております
+ハンディキャップの尾崎はずないと言いますよろしくお願いします
今日はバリアフリーに新たにするということでまず皆さんにこのスライドを見てもらう
ところから始めたいと思います
おば c
実は僕の足なんですけれどもこの足を持っているといいますかこの橋の人が日常生活を
送る上で困ることは何でしょう
困ること
これを例えば小学校奏楽体の前で応援をしたときに出てくるを耐えたしたら
あることですかっ
走ることですか
青プロに入ることじゃないですかというような答えができません
もちろんそれらの答えはすべて正しいんですが実は僕自身が困っていることそれは
ファッションと恋愛と駅
ここ見てる
人ですね
このペットっていう漫画ためにちょっと普通をおニューの靴を履いていたんですけど
紫色の味月
あと1か月で3ヶ月すれば3カーの2床はセフレてしまいます
それは僕自身がある方によるものがあります
恋愛というとこの橋の持ってる人そもそも相手のパートナーである女性が受け入れて
くれるのかどうかその気持ちというのはすごく不安なものがあります
本人腰が劇であったとしても障害に対して連携を骨
パーソンなど後良品をいれば黄砂蟻道が出ることがあります
実際に僕自身もその経験をしたことができません
また席すっというものが書いてありますけれどもせっかくこう
よる ebu のなのに au 中で小橋が出てきたとき
相手に聞かれたらどうしよう驚かれたらどうしよ
そういう気持ちがの衣のも g です
実際僕らは足が不自由だとあるほど走ることなどに困るということも事実ですけれども
実は本人が抱えているない事っていうものが違ったりします
これが僕が考えるそもそもと矛盾デー
いらいい
僕がが消える仕事というのは
皆さんの中にある偏見や思い込みにあるいは固定蔓延することを明確にすることです
阿部さーん今持つ0学
足が不自由であればあることを走ることが大変なんじゃないから
でも実際放置者が抱えてるないですけどまたべきものです
僕はこの二面の仕事あっ
この自分の仕事を翻訳という風に言ってい
僕の目のとしていますでも基準な友人の女性の子達は
サーセン c ぐらい冷やすかありません
3センチくらいしかないのにその人はいけるようにせて一目惚れします
またオペな友人の優品てでの人もなくですね
飲み友達の曲ひょこのある消費の男性
この人は平時の最初にプロレスラー
勝也見せたり
実際に総額 pro l 3分
つまり
障害をかかえ
っていう状況の中で皆さんの頭の中における
できること多いことができるんじゃないかな
こういうことができないじゃないかなっていうところに
思い違いがある
僕らはこのできることの思い期待できない小物重い機材がある限りいい
この社会にバリアフリーの境が訪れるとは考えていません
つまり今の
この社会に立って一番の問題権というのは知らないからわからないん
その知らないから分からないという部分が
ポインタ思い違いを引き起こすず
3人バリアフリーユニバーサルデザインという言葉が
開いて語られるようになっています
オレはー
外部用はサーフ面の生涯やし攻撃ってことをフリーにしていきましょう
その劇が多くの人にとって暮らしやすい街づくり
暮らしや仕事を作っていきましょうということがこの考え方です
ダイバーシティーやリンクルージュインクルージョン愛煙クルージュデザインとも言わ
れますか
これは大変的なバリアフリーの部分をします
ただこのバリアフリーが抱いてるね
ivanka つけていただいたよねそういった言葉を使っていたりそういった
取り組みで企業の中で
サービスを回したりプロジェクトオファーしていたりする人たちが僕らが抱えている
当事者が抱えている
小針事だったり
できないことだったり不安なことだったり
いうのを
オゾンってなんでしょうか
本も言えば網羅的に知っているのでしょうか
これを知らない状態で進めていくぞ
それがユニークが伴います
今から話すことは決してフレームではありません
皆さん今日この icu 行ったときにも見たかもしれませんし
触町の中でも見たかもしれませんがページブログというものがあります
で白というのは目月中の人にとってはその融合する
自分が引くバスを融合する大切な大切なツールです
しかし義足を入れる僕にとっては
雨が降った時にそのページブロックで滑ることがあるん
今ちょうど3歳になる息子がいるんですが息子がベビーカーに乗っていた時はよく寝
ジプロックに全員が集まってきました
つまりバリアフリーのためにあるそういったアイテムだったり
欲しいデザインといったものが
違う方に打ってのバリアになっている
こういったにつながることも今ま新
相関配当
実は
バリアフリーという言葉の中には放射不在という状態があります
本当に困っている人にとってそれは便利なものだとか
メリットがあるものとか価値があるものだとか
その検証がでれていないこれが二つの課題4 a
あたしたちの皆さんに声をかけたいと思います
またはが出てきました僕の足です
正直よく見るとです猫すべきが入ってたりとか
爪が伸びたりあまり綺麗なことではないんですか
この橋の人
人生を楽しく生きることができるでしょうか
実際僕自身は平気で探して生きてい
巻き込ま李帆それぞれあると思いますが恋愛にしますたち
今作るには
素敵な船凸的なウツボがありません
あー家族っていいなぁと思いながらこうしていますがじつは生涯活という言葉の
イメージの奥には
大変そうとか新塗装他+他
そういったネガティブなイメージが付きまとっています
このネガティブなイメージと実際にベジすす
ほぼギャップこのズレがあることによって
紹介さに対するイメージが上がり良くないものだったり
そしてこっペイの番組部景観になってしまうかもしれませんが
反動ポルノとかを涙商材といったことがに反映されることがあります
これを実は
障害者が
楽しく生きてい
楽しく暮らしていると言うサンプルがないからです
妻ひさきほどバリアフリーの時に某被削材
知らないからわからないそういう話がありましたが実際現在社会的ヴァイオリ t と
言われている方が楽しく生きているサンプルというのもこの社会安くないという評価
です
だからこそ社会版を知らないからわからないです
当社側も自分の未来とや利益が描けない
だからわからないんだから怖い
そういう状態が続いています
先ほどプラ三脚でが生きづらさというものをテーマにして今活動していると言いました
さ
2013年の3月に+ハンディキャップというウェブメディアを開発していない
何十本何百ほぼコラムを書いてみましたが奴と nhk の番組なったり
新聞べリアで生きづらさという言葉が出てくるようになりました
ここにかけても僕個人が見た者としては発達障害の生きづらさ
貧困家庭の行きづらかっそういったことを見ています
あっ正直に言うと僕らの方が先にいざという言葉を使いましたので安と時代ボーイ税率
だから
そういうような感覚すらもありますが今この池つだったというのはおっコマンドだと
思います
僕のプレゼンは結構今ですね元気神戸市
追ってなかったりするので上でどうちょっと役の人たちがすごく開く石膏されてると
思うんですが
てくださっていうのを英語で言うとどういう言葉になるなかどう表現になるのかなって
いうのは他にしても今すごく悩んでいるところです
それこそアートツーリングなのか
いや怒るとかもしれない no 本当かもしれない
やっと授かったもしれない
張り子かな
いろいろなことを考えているともう生きづらさせていうのは
過労地のようにですね
英語になってしまってもいいんじゃないかなことそれくらい思う
おそらく日本独自の
メンタル的な部分だと思います
ただそれは引きずら去っているは僕らは解釈論だと考えてい
僕自身義息を吐いていて生まれて障害を持っていてここまで30年以上障害者という
キャリアを積んできました
ただ今まで周囲の友達だったり仕事仲間だったり
家族だったりあ頭の中に恵まれた部分によって
あまり甲府幸せか持っていません
のまで来てきたの仕方だ幸せだなあというふうに言うまあ正直いつ死んでもいいなって
思えるくらい楽しいですよ思います
ただ世の中にはすごいを障害があることによって戻すバッフル趣味
あーしんどいもどかしい辛い寂しいしてつないはなしー
それで死にたいというような気持ちを持っている障害のあるかと思います
ということばっ
障害というものによって
生きづらさが生まれるわけではない
この障害というものをどうをこらえるぱ
どう開始するかによって
生きづらさが決まりません
おっというと行きやすさ暮らしや下がっております
ただこれも先ほど言ったように知らないから分からないいう世界が広がっています
僕にしていっ
小学生ところにお外いますという本がありました
その時に
抑止ラーメンおばちゃんから
いや日に目標があっても頑張っていけない言われます
掃除機とおばさん知らない人だったんでお前誰だよ
そういう気持ちがあったんですがそんな中
をかけさんがなくなきゃいけないん
いやもうちょっと普通の金製でいいんですけど別に本を出したり不そういうわけでは
なくて普通に楽しい人生が遅れればいい
実は今社会的マイノリティ言われるような形のこの
ちょうどいいアンプルがないんですん
それこそ社会で楽しく暮らしている普通の場合の力属性部活
このサンプルがないというのが生きづらさを生み出している
大きな要因なのではないかと僕らは考えていません
知らないからわからない
社会がはも大阪何に困っているのか知らないからわからないん
そして放射がは生きづらさを抱えているばお
自分たちにとって良い案それがないからわからないん
知らないからわからないだから想像できない
社会いってばリアの愛社会一発豪遊社会だとか
生きづらさを抱えて等しい得で楽しい人生とはどういったものを追う
この情報がないから
方法できないん
つまり僕らができるラサ吐き出すというメディアの活動
小顔狩りで初て25口径させてもらいますが
僕らはこの女に取り組むために今活動していることと自負していた
そしてこの造語を持っていない人は社会がありも
公社側にも言えることの胸に
僕らとしては社会向けの発信もするし王子者向けの発信をしていたり
そういう気持ちでいます
生きづらさには一つパラドックスのような状況があります
さきほども言いました生きづらさを踏み出していくこと
解釈の問題ですがこれには情報が少ないからその状況が生まれているというふうに話し
ました
でも
例えば障害者を踏む
で開きだしますが
足の二重唱会社が恋愛に困っている生活に困っている
明日に来抜粋品消耗を持っている誰なんですよ
おそらく弊社の祖といわれる皆さんが持っているわけではありません
つまり
当時車マギー生きづらさを抱えている社会的マイノリティ
いろんなことがありますがこの候補者が抱えている情報というものを当事者自身が持っ
ていることによって社会に浸透していない
だから社会がはで例えば無理解がヘイ危険な差別意識だそういったこともがでてりで
実際
王者の僕に帰っ
つまりここにはパラとふっポーズがあるわけです
生きづらさを抱えている人たちがどれだけ情報を発信してきた
どれだけ構造をしていくか
これからは社会日に前の良いが自分たちの暮らしやすさを勝ち取るため
暮らしやすを得るために自分たちから足をしていかないと意味がないいい時代になって
きます
このアクションには
例えば理解してほしい貼ってほしいというか感情に対する訴求が必要ありません
頭で自分自身の人生を自分自身で主導権を握って自分自身の整理なものもの力てい
そのために例えば社会があり配慮も感じない
必要なものが足りないのであれば自分たちカフェー熱い
もちろん
社会がありまして大変平野にたしたいばっかりだとか
社会がも良くなればいいのにと思って自分たちで社会に対してはアクションを起こして
いこう
これ大切だと思う
ただ入られるのは自分でいいだけです
過去と濃さを変えられませんし社会を変えるには
馬区内のおじさんおば比べ費用が分かります
であれば
これから暮らしやすさを経ているためには社会的前よりに言われている人たち
もっと言えばちょっといい絵づらさを抱えている普通の人たちも自分自身の人生を自分
自身が主導権を握ってい
そう言っていいのではないでしょうか
僕なグラスハチェットが考えていることは自分が変われば周囲が変わる
周囲が彼が社会が変わっています
自分自身の候補に塩
どうすれば自分が幸せになれるのかどうしてか自分が楽しく生きられるのかと思い
帰り行くことができれば人生はきっと欲しいものになっていきます
今日のこの経歴最新いうのテーマバーっという言葉です
人と人とが仲良くなったり違いをフォント仕上げそういう社会になるためには
自分自身が過去だったりたさと比較せずに二類の編成を自分が歩むその決意を持って
あげてる人が多ければ多いほど実は他社にとっても寛容の社会が生まれるのではない
でしょうか
僕はそういう社会を目指して多くの色々な人達に対して
言葉を投げかけてこれから活動していきたいと思いますご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]
ん